foreign
the upcoming butterfly effect of Bert
kreischer's new movie The Machine may be
a lot more significant than anyone quite
understands leading up to the premiere
including bird stand-up comedian
starring in box office movies is
obviously not new from Jim Carrey's
insane stretch of Classics in the early
90s Kevin Hart's recent run of huge
comedy films or even Andrew Schultz's
appearance in the remake of White Men
Can't Jump plenty of comedians have been
hired to act on the big screen but never
before has a studio taken quite as large
of a chance on a comic like Sony is
right now on Bert Kreischer and his new
movie The Machine the story that was
made famous 12 years ago as the closing
joke in Birds act and has been performed
in front of audiences all around the
world is now just two days away from
being released in movie form it took
Sony nearly two years and 35 million
dollars to create Bert's movie so it's
safe to assume they're more than fully
invested in making sure that the machine
is a box office hit but despite
everything at risk leading up to the
premiere all of these Hollywood execs
were still willing to give Bert kreiser
total creative control so you can get
your tickets that's very cool man I'm
excited for it I really want I haven't
seen it I think you'll I think you'll
like it I think you'll be distracted
because you're gonna go yeah the only
thing that anyone has seen it says is I
can't believe you can act that like
that's everyone says that we've been
witnessing this new age of comedian
empowerment for a few years now with
more comics than ever producing their
own shows movies and specials which so
far seemed to work out pretty great for
Comedians and at the same time has kind
of hurt traditional media so it is
pretty rare to see a comedian leading
the production and getting their way on
a movie of this size of magnitude that
cost 35 million dollars and features
[__] Luke Skywalker they've given me
so much control it's to the point where
I go like I'm like I keep going like I'm
just a [__] comic like I don't know
like especially with the marketing and
like they I mean I leaked the trailer in
Tampa this is exactly why it's going to
be so interesting to see how Bert's
movie performs financially let's quickly
explore both possible outcomes being
option one the movie does very well in
option two it's a gigantic flop if the
Machine movie performs well in theaters
and generates enough money in the eyes
of the studio they would likely start
seeking out comedians to not only star
in but also write direct and help guide
these future big budget movies meaning
the total butterfly effect of Bert
kreischer's original comedy origin story
spending seven years in college which
led to him traveling to Russia
experiencing the events that led to the
machine's story having him tell the
story on Rogan Joe convincing Bert to
Tell It On Stage is a joke which led to
Bert posting the story online the clip
going insanely viral and becoming the
main propeller of Bert's entire career
23 years later gets made into a hit box
office movie which leads to more Studios
investing into more comedians starting a
new wave of companies making good comedy
movies again written by real comedians
who already have massive fan bases that
will go support and see their work no
matter what but even more interesting
than all of that combined this same
exact butterfly effect that started Bert
kreischer's comedy career could
hypothetically be the thing that causes
him to stop doing stand-up altogether
selfishly I want the movie to do well
because I want to do machine two three
and four I want to sign on now and
that's all I want to do the rest of my
life yeah it's just making machine
movies it's like if Sylvester Stallone
just did Rambo yeah so I want the
machine nine and I want to go to space
but that's okay so selfishly I wanted to
do well because I want to do machine two
three four and five I want to do machine
movies that's for the rest of my life
yeah that would be my dream my dream is
to milk this story until its tits hurt
some would say oh we're already there go
ahead selflessly selflessly if this
machine movie does well yeah I can all
but guarantee you will see the movie
theaters flooded with Comics doing
movies I I guarantee I completely agree
with that so if the movie performing
super well like it did in option one
could somehow cause Bert Chrysler to
stop not doing stand-up comedy
altogether what the hell could possibly
happen in option two if the Machine
movie for whatever reason is considered
a flop by Sony it would most likely
cause large Studios to think twice about
working with comedians outside of their
Hollywood bubble for a while comedians
would still continue to self-produce new
Innovative content whether that be
movies festivals sketch shows or
specials with personal budgets from
patreon and YouTube support like we've
seen in the past Bert would be
relatively fine as well even though the
machine franchise wouldn't take off like
you dreamed of it's not like he was the
one that put up the 35 million dollars
plus if we're being honest Bert has
enough DieHard fans and this story's got
enough tread left on its tires for me to
assume that the machine will do big
numbers in theaters this Thursday and
now it's time for a word from the
sponsor of today's video Ridge with
Father's Day right around the corner
Ridge is making gifting easy with one of
their biggest sales of the year the
ridge wall can expand and hold up to 12
cards at once plus room for cash while
still remaining super slim ridge's
durable material alongside their fifty
thousand five star reviews mean that
each wallet comes with a lifetime
warranty which is pretty 36 dads also
seem to have a lot of keys Rich key
cases easily hold one to six keys and
prevent any annoying jingling find the
best Father's Day gift using
rlinkridge.com joke world and right now
you can save up to 40 through June 15th
that's rich.com joke World guest spots
from last week your mom's house had on
Josh Potter two bears one cave was Burt
and Kevin Smith kill Tony this week was
with Paulie Shore and Eric Griffin we
might be drunk out on Rachel Feinstein
Dove David off was a guest on Christy
chaos the youngest papasauer had on Jay
Larson whiskey Ginger talks with
Courtney Wayne and Danny McBride was on
Matt and Shane's secret podcast I'm just
like if you don't do it they're younger
throw your stuff I'll do it now I'll do
it I'll take a Kindle and put it on top
of the trash gently like it's done away
books yeah dude
do you take their stuff and you're like
all right good keep reading yeah well no
they're they're using it yeah okay like
my move is like I just will like change
my tone real fast and start counting and
then they're just like don't even know
what to say today
it's the only thing to hear countdown as
a kid is terrifying like what's at the
end of this what do I need to do to stop
the clock that's a lot going on dude
yeah lights go off in the classroom that
was always that always got me kind of
like oh [__] this lady's not [__]
around
yeah
what else is up
this past weekend with the Yvonne had on
Will Sasso The Joe Rogan Experience had
on Jelly Roll Tom takar was on are you
garbage Jordan Jensen was a guest on
take your shoes off with Rick Glassman
Anthony Ferrara was on the Honeydew
Derek Gaines and Dave Temple were on
stavy's world atsco catsko was on the
blocks podcast Greg Stone was on you
know what dude and Meghan Trainor was on
tigerbelly as far as new stand-up
specials go They're either out right now
have been out for a while or are coming
out soon those are the three options
Chris Porter there's no money in babies
is also out on YouTube as well and if
you're looking for a shorter special to
watch this week Drew Landry All My
Friends Are Dead is also out you guessed
it on YouTube I'll tell you a story when
I was eight years old my best friend
died in a horrible freak accident stay
with me I'm okay I'm only telling you
this info because without it the joke
isn't funny so he died
and my parents made an executive
decision they decided that because I was
already depressed to keep me from
feeling worse they were gonna Shield me
from bad things that happened in the
news they were like Drew's in a fragile
place so for the sake of his mental
health if anything scarier depressing
happens on the news we're gonna make
sure he doesn't find out about it on
paper that's not a bad idea but my
friend died in late August 2001.
[Applause]
which is a bad time to stop telling
someone about the news
how many videos on YouTube we posted a
half hour crowd work compilation a few
days ago that has some really funny
moments and features over 20 comedians
so give that a shot if you're bored
later this week and keep your eyes out
for some more joke World videos coming
up in the next few days you might as
well subscribe and turn on the post
notifications if I'm being honest but
that's up to you no pressure thank you
for watching
and that world is wrld
[Music]